one plus two plus three plus four
plus five plus six and so on
does it make any sense the sum I mean
you probably heard about this one it
became a very popular at some point one
plus two plus three I did I did a video
for number file the the YouTube channel
about it maybe 10 years ago so one plus
two plus three plus four plus five
ostensibly
uh diverges goes to Infinity because you
got a bigger and bigger number and yet
there is a way to make sense of it
in which it this it comes up to minus
one over twelve
how fascinating first of all the answer
is not even a positive number and it's
not an integer it's not a whole number
it's minus one over twelve so sometimes
people ask me what is your favorite
number
and it's a kind of a joke I say minus
one over twelve
it's actually 42.
it's uh your favorite number is not an
ordered set
uh right so what else what else uh so
placements program of course I have to
mention that and we'll we'll explore
that in depth do you want do you want to
know what Eric said sure sphere aversion
boys surface hop vibration vibration
okay and
Pi one of SO3 okay oh yes so that's the
that's the famous cup trick you know
okay look so this is how it works
no tricks no tricks no matter honest it
is magical okay
not because I'm tricking you so you
start with a a bottle like this or a cup
and you start twisting it at the same
time you twist your your arm then you
come so this is actually going to
um rotate at 360 Degrees the full turn
then you say okay I won't be able to do
another turn because then my arm would
really get twisted I'll have to go see a
dog yet if I do it second time it
untwists
this is the by one of SO3 Erica's
talking about yes so there is something
where
the first motion is not reveal but if
you double down on it you come back to
the initial position
it's a very closely connected to the
fact that we have Elementary particles
of two types bosons and fermions
so bosons are for example photons or
carriers of other forces or the Higgs
boson it is called a boson for a reason
because it is a Boson uh in in honor of
Indian mathematician Bose b-o-s-e and
Einstein so this particles obey what's
called both Einstein statistics but then
there are other particles called
fermions
in honor of Enrico Fermi Italian porn
mathematician who worked in in the US
and and they follow what's called Iraq
Fermi statistics and those are electrons
and constituents of matter electrons
protons neutrons and so on and they have
a certain duplicity if you will and that
duplicity is rooted mathematically in
this in this experiment this little
experiment that I have just done
so I can I imagine speaking of
imagination okay yeah so I'm just kind
of briefing on this imagine a world in
which this will not be shocking or like
in this case it's not even shocking
because I haven't really explained the
details because I can't do it in two
minutes I I indicated
what this is all about and so on
but imagine a world in which this is not
for into most people that most people
have seen it before or they're not
afraid to approach this type of
questions because you know we talked a
little bit about Mass education but I
really believe that a lot of people in
our society and it is not not only in
the United States but throughout the
world a lot of people have been
traumatized
it's really PTSD that's why people when
they see might make a formula or like
even like how can they need to calculate
tip on the bill they it's just they're
terrified because it brings up those
memories when they were kids and being
called to Blackboard
and
solve the problem you can solve a
problem and ask groupless teacher says
you're an idiot sit down and you feel
ashamed and and then lowly and that
stays with you and so I think that
unfortunately that's where we are
dream and so my dream is that one day
we'll be able to overcome this
and actually all of these Treasures of
mathematics
will become widely widely available or
at least people will know where to find
them
and they will not be afraid of going
there and looking and I think this will
help because like I said for one thing
it gives you a sense of belonging it
gives you it kind of is an antidote the
kind of alienation and separation that
we feel today oftentimes because of
ideological divide
sectarian strife and all kinds of things
like that because then you will once you
see there's a critical mass of this
beauty
that kind of like tones on you is like
my God this is what we all have in
common